today we're gonna have a look at data
visualization data visualization is a
way of representing information in a
artistic way in an interesting way
scientists might be happy with scatter
plots and black and white boring graphs
but if you want to communicate
information and data to the public you
want it to be fun you want to be
enjoyable you want it to be colorful and
we thought we might have a look at a
particular guys work I called Martin
Kavinsky today we're actually going to
look at some of his more number Ebert
artistic work so we're gonna have a look
at him finding Beauty so we say artistry
in the randomness of Pi so we've got it
down here this is PI in a beautiful
colorful way now this is first of all
the most simple way I think that you
could have done this all he's done is
taken the digits of pi and it's given
each digit a different color so it
starts with three so it looks like three
is an orange color there one is all red
four is a yellow one again is red and
then five it's green and I think that's
a nine that's purple it's made this
really beautiful poster you can kind of
see the randomness of it though I don't
see there's any particular pattern to
the colors which is which reflects the
randomness of the digits of pi as well
he took that a step further and he
started to do color the center of the
circles using the color of the next
digit I I think he only did that just to
make it and it's a bit prettier but he
was I think he found it interesting
because he started to join up digits
that had the same colors in them which
looks like this there we go
can you see that so he's connected
digits or adjacent digits in his poster
that have the same color so they'd be
the same number and he kind of makes
these disconnected networks I don't
think this any great mathematical truth
to find underneath this this is for art
and Martin's very clear about this
himself the
is less about the mathematics and more
about the beauty of it but it is
intriguing as well the other way you
could do this is if you put the digits
of pi in a spiral like this this kind of
reminds me of the tiding you know in a
Roman bathhouse something like that
maybe that's the colors he's used but to
take this a step further and this I
think is one of our favorites yeah I
think this is one of Brady's favorites
isn't it yes I think we should just
appreciate the beauty of that for a
moment before we describe it before we
ruin really the beauty of it by
describing it because appreciate that
now what he's done there he's connected
the digits together as you go through
the digits of pi so he started at 3 and
then he's connected 3 2 1
so you'll go here and he's connected 1 2
4 so it will go down here and he's
connected 4 2 1 so it goes back to 1
then it'll go to 5 and that'll go to 9
and he's connecting them in that way and
it's also given each digit a color as
well so it's like a path he's made a
path he's put the numbers in a circle 0
1 2 3 4 5 up to 9 and you've made a path
and it makes this beautiful circular
piece of art data visualizations hugely
important it goes way back and when we
talk about Florence Nightingale she had
to represent her statistics that she had
in the Crimean War when she was a nurse
and the deaths that she was suffering on
the wards it was because they weren't
clean enough and she would represent
this data she was a mathematician
herself Florence Nightingale fantastic
and she had these things called Rose
diagrams which I actually think are
hideous
but they are similar idea they're
representing data in a visual way I mean
a more simple example of that is a pie
graph representing data in a visual way
and what these guys now and I think it's
become quite a
recently is to make it beautiful as well
and that's important because to
communicate especially to the general
public you want to be able to look at
this information understand it and enjoy
looking at it and you'll appreciate it
better we can talk about serious
mathematics subjects like combinatorics
which is very visual as well and you can
then do maths through pictures and
diagrams and things like this networks
and graph theory and things like that in
this example that we've got here there
is actually something we can look at so
we think that pi is pretty random
Martin actually compared pi here with a
few randomly generated numbers so he
generated these aren't pi these are
randomly generated numbers he did the
same sort of artistry and you can see
the similar sorts of patterns coming
through the pi has the appearance of a
randomly generated number another piece
of art by martin is the same idea again
our circular paths but here he's put
little dots on the outside just to show
you where the the lines are coming from
and where they're going to so if it's
3.14 1 then above the 3 he's shown it
with a little dot that it's going to the
number 1 and then above the 1 it shows
that he's come from the number 3 it's
just showing where it's going to and
where it's coming from
so the size of thoughts means it's that
this occurs more often actually look
look at this one there's a big purple
dot and this shows that it's actually
purple it means 9 and it's above the 9
here what it's showing is it's there's a
there's a sequence in PI that is just 9
9 9 9 it's the Feynman point which I
know Brady is a big fan of which is six
consecutive nines somewhere around the
760 something digit I think it's 760 to
digit in pi and you can see it that is
there
those are six consecutive nines and it
makes a big blob because it's coming
from nine repeated three repeatedly
Barton has done this for other numbers
as well he's done it for the golden
ratio another famous mathematical number
I stand this for II another famous
mathematical number and what he was
interested in though when he started
doing that was where they coincide what
he did is he lined up these three
special mathematical numbers he lined
them up and he wanted to look at where
they had the same digit now because
these numbers are kind of random really
when they have the same digit that's
just random so for all three numbers to
have the same digit that happens with
the probability of one in a hundred but
when he lined them up he got something
he called the accidental similarity
number and he discovered that yes they
do line up with the same digit about one
in a hundred which is what probability
tells us so they have a sort of an
average gap between lining up of about
100 and he started to experiment with
his accidental similarity number he made
some pieces of art based on that as well
there you go here's another piece is
another one of our circular ones here
and doesn't it look pretty he should go
to his website as well where he'll
explain more details about how all these
things were made
[Music]
can you do that again and this time talk
me through it as you don't you ask a lot
pretty